he calls himself the daughter of the
Dragon she was it funny how we're having
again right there
I don't know where you came from
you're welcome anytime when we sent me
Colleen she's just trying to survive
cuts begin
Colleen works in a dojo yeah yeah she
looks off the kids these exercises are
about trying to teach you how to perform
in the real world she represents honor
discipline self discipline she has this
edge how about you add another fighter
when I win you double my payday you are
one crazy chick you know that Colleen
isn't a lot of financial trouble she's
in such dire straits she ends up going
to a Fight Club you're ready for the
part of your lord ends up liking it
[Applause]
that is never seen women is strong in
its business Colleen I want challenge
matter he has to win her over
I'm asking you nicely to be a first
initial reaction is you're crazy that
when she sees how good of a fighter is
she starts to realize that's something
else about him
[Music]
very dangerous
very dangerous she's curious he's so
intriguing and he's so unlike anyone
who's ever met if she will kill you
that's not going to happen so she kind
of takes a gamble we can do a lot of
good together
was the only person who can help me it's
a very dramatic relationship
mysteries such a big part of our show
and there's an element of what its fate
was it meant to be I think she knows
it's Danny's not good for her but it's
intoxicating I'm going with you
so you're not anything Colleen is
amazing people will not work great
feminine figure shoes
I insist is in a league of its own it
just shows that keeps you on your toes
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so I got to see
the first six episodes of iron fist so
this is going to be my non-spoilery
video for that first story arc I totally
love Colleen link she has this
infectious energy about her so I'll talk
about her during my top ten here this is
non spoilery so don't worry if you new
to the channel I do Marvel videos every
week comic book stuff be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's going to be a lot of iron fist
happening a lot of other Marvel stuff
too and I'll explain why everybody's
going so crazy with the review they're a
bunch of critics that are going crazy
about it but I'll address season two
defenders immortal weapons all the good
stuff so number ten they're doing an
origin story just like they did for the
other Marvel Netflix series so if you
remember the way that daredevil Luke
Cage Jessica Jones handled those origin
stories you pick up with the characters
in a sort of action sequence as they're
getting they're called to action and
then they start flashing back to the
origin story so it's not a completely
linear experience they try to find
interesting ways to do all that
exposition because even though daredevil
that was a concept of resurrecting
Elektra which is pretty wild Iron Fist
goes way beyond that
you're talking about the seven capital
cities of heaven the immortal weapons
the heart of the Dragon Shu Lao so
there's just so many big concepts that
they have to find really easy ways of
explaining because this is built for
anybody to watch like it's built for the
fan but you have to imagine that they
planned it out in the way they planned
daredevil out so they could explain the
character to people that have never read
the comic book so if you have read Iron
Fist even if you don't remember a whole
lot about the character you'll still
spot a whole bunch of Easter eggs but
just like Luke Cage comes back after a
long absence in his hometown so does
Iron Fist he sort of had to like
recenter himself in the community now
the big changes is that he's a
billionaire and he has to prove his
identity and take his company back from
evil forces so they sort of address who
that is that's sort of like the big arc
of the first half of the season so just
like Luke Cage had to get rid of
cottonmouth and all the crap that was
going on in Harlem a version of that is
happening for Danny ran but the big bad
for him is actually the hand
organization they're a much bigger deal
during the Iron Fist series so number 9
the comic book origin story versus the
TV show origin story so if you don't
know what the con
iron fist origin story is iron fist got
his powers by fighting and defeating the
dragon Shu Lao the Dragon itself is this
mystical creature that hatched from an
egg every 80 plus years it's basically
like the lifespan of an iron fist so
when there's an iron fist around he is
the defender of his capital city of
heaven there are seven capital cities of
heaven iron this is the defender of
conlon so when you become the new iron
fist you defeat the dragon you take the
power from its heart and you becomes a
defender of that city but what happens
is is that after you defeat the dragon
there's sort of the cycle of death and
rebirth a new egg is hatched in a new
Dragon grows from that egg so that the
next Iron Fist when they come along many
many years down the road can defeat it
take its power it becomes a new defender
of the city
the immortal weapons are the defenders
of each of those seven capital cities of
heaven each of them gets their power
from a different source they have very
different abilities but it's very kung
fu based it's all really trippy but you
have to remember that the Marvel Netflix
series is taking place in New York City
not in con LUN
so there's not as much immortal weapon
stuff going on as you would might think
and that just flows from iron fist
sort of having to fit in with the other
defender so this is a very street-level
show so if you just got done reading the
comic book they're waiting into the deep
end of that pool slowly so eventually
will work up to a lot of that stuff
number eight the criticism that you've
probably been hearing about the show
from critics is mostly about the pacing
of the first six episodes remember
they've only screened the first six for
critics there are a lot of people to
think it's a racial thing I'm not going
to talk about that at all please don't
get super racial in the comments let's
try to keep this fun about the
comic-book stuff the reason the first
story arc of the season feels like a
slow bird is because Danny Rand comes
back they have to tell the origin story
who he is where he's been where he's
going and what he has to do the minute
that he comes back so it's sort of him
stepping into this hornet's nest of hand
that has taken over his family's company
so the first arc of the season just like
Luke Cage is sort of dealing with that
so I think a lot of critics are just mad
with the amount of time they spent on
that storyline but remember
you're getting to all the big comic-book
iron fist up the back half of the season
so you have to build up to that the
other Netflix series did the exact same
thing so if you've seen any of the other
series you kind of know how they paced
their shows number seven Colleen wing is
an early addition to the series she's
one of the main characters gets her own
version of an origin story she's one of
the best characters on the show I'm so
happy with the way it went down
Jessica hen wick has this childlike
energy about her it's almost like
watching Tom Holland play spider-man
like oh my god this is the most amazing
fun thing ever so I was really happy
with the way her storyline went down
they're actually using her to market the
series right now which I feel like it
was a really good decision so great
performance great character it's going
to be a lot of fun to see what she does
in the back half of the season number 6
calling lean comic book stuff this is
actually kind of funny so they had to
step around a lot of big stuff that
they're working up to for later but she
and Misty night in the comics had a
detective agency
so get this it was originally called
Nightwing investigation so already huge
copyright problem later in the comics
they change that to daughters of the
Dragon so like they haven't done misty
Knight with the bionic arm yet there's a
lot of things that they have to work up
to but there's so much crossover with
the characters that number 5 a lot of
the Luke Cage stuff that happened during
that series spills over into iron fist
primarily through the Claire temple
character who also continues to be one
of the best things about the Marvel
Netflix series so rosario Dawson is
totally amazing during iron fist she
takes way more but it's going to be a
lot more fun but you know because of the
proximity of Harlem where all the Luke
Cage characters come from there's a lot
of iron fist spillover so that's why in
the comics we see Danny Rand spending a
lot of his time up closer to Harlem but
you remember health kitchen where
Daredevil and Jessica Jones live is
right down here so geographically most
of Iron Fist takes place in Midtown so
you're a little bit further down here
but because he's a billionaire he moves
around a lot more than other characters
in fact he owns a lot of buildings in
Manhattan just to enable him to run
across the rooftops and get around
really fast that is one of the many ways
he uses his wealth to help his
crime-fighting skills number four the
threat of the hand they're like the big
bad for almost all of the net
Cirie's so they're a much bigger thing
during Iron Fist he is the
self-described mortal enemy of the hand
and he comes out of Conlan knowing about
all that so the thing that stick was
trying to tell daredevil about during
season one and season two Maddie you
gotta listen there's much bigger
concerns the war between the hand and
the chase Iron Fist is way more
concerned than the other characters with
the threat is coming like Jessica Jones
if you told her about crazy ninjas that
resurrect people she would probably
throw her drink at you what I'm
expecting from the Netflix series is
that they're going to change a little
bit of Iron Fist immortal weapons
storyline where you know he's mostly
concerned with what's going on in the
seven capital cities of heaven every
once in a while somebody from one of
those cities goes crazy and they have to
put him down but because we're easing
into that he's mostly dealing with his
human problems especially in the first
six episodes so it seems like you know
number three Madame Gao who is sort of
like the crane mother of the series you
learn why she's so worried about iron
fist and why nothing seems to bother her
in how they're incorporating those
capital cities of heaven into the hand
storyline it seems like they're crossing
a lot of streams so Madame Gao is the
leader of one of the other capital
cities of heaven in the comics but she's
pretty evil so she works through other
agents like the steel serpent to bring
about the destruction of the other
capital cities of heaven Madame galin
the series is kind of like a kingpin
type character that's the way they're
using are very powerful in her own right
who is working with the hand without
necessarily being part of the hand so my
guess is is that what will happen is is
that in season two of Iron Fist season
three you'll see more of Madame Gao side
of the story in the other capital cities
of heaven so more on that though they
tease that there are two mystery
characters that are coming in the back
half of the season one of them is
supposed to be the steel serpent the
other one I'm hoping is Orson Randall
who was the previous iron fist he's sort
of like a stick for iron fist a wise old
mentor who used to be iron fist himself
it has the same powers number two the
villains that they have confirmed for
this series is zhu chang who is working
for crane mother in the comics he's
descended from the lightning lords of
nepal this group of iron fist villains
with
you guessed it Lightning based powers
his powers are kind of on the level of
steel serpent in terms of abilities he's
someone who is possessed by a demon that
has enough power to challenge the iron
fist but it's a much more powerful
version of Danny red I don't think the
TV show is going to do it directly but
the demon that possesses him is actually
after the dragon's egg that birds shoo
loud the source of iron fist' power the
TV showed just like the other Netflix
series has toned down a lot of the
really really crazy stuff so just expect
the same treatment for a lot of the
crazy comic book villains that they
introduced number one though the series
is leading directly into defenders which
is dropping this summer probably later
this summer because they're still
filming it right now they're also still
working on the Punisher which is
supposed to drop much later this year
but I think it just depends on when they
finish filming when they can get the
episodes out so maybe as late as
September for defenders episode one but
they confirm there be a three to six
month time jump from the last episode of
iron fist to the first episode of
defenders so you have to imagine like
you meet Danny Rand in Episode one of
iron fist looking like this and this is
what he looks like in the middle of the
defenders series so he has a pretty big
arc during the first season but it's on
par with the other Netflix characters
overall if you're a big comic book fan I
think you'll have a lot of fun with the
series just remember that it is a slow
burn for the first arc of the season
till it gets into the really big comic
book stuff in the back half if you are a
fan of the daredevil comic book and you
like the way this series handled that
character it's going to be the same deal
for iron fist what I'm going to do later
this week is that my iron fist videos
will just be Easter eggs for blocks of
episode so I'll do like the first two or
three episodes together then I'll do the
next two or three and so on and so forth
through the rest of the series but let
me know in the comments if you have any
special requests if you want me to do
videos for the comic book or talk more
about the immortal weapons or any of
those stories the giveaways will still
be going on when I do those and there'll
be new flash posting later tonight new
episode where you wait for that you can
click here to get ready for the flash
tonight and you can click here to listen
to Danny ran talked about teaming up
with Luke Cage thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight
you